well hello reject nation it's Greg Alba
here and Kat Alvarado the cat Alvarado
on social media and cowbell comedy up
Facebook is here with me today to watch
the trailer for I Tanya she's helping me
catch him on trailers cuz I was a little
ill earlier this week had Alvarado if
for you guys who were in the East Coast
New York New Jersey that area she's
gonna be performing comedy out there
from November 5th through November 9th
and here are the dates for you guys
specifically November 5th at 6 and
November 6 at 6 both at the Eastvale
comedy club November 7th at 8:30 at the
mockingbird November 8th at 8:00 at to
boots Brooklyn they have good pizza in
November it's New York and November 9th
at 8 the comedy cope comedy coves at
Scotty's in Springfield New Jersey if
you're the East Coast you caught this
video save the date people save the day
anyway she knows something about Tonya
Harding that I don't know which is I
know nothing about I'm just like beat
the crap out of some other chick with a
baseball bat and they were competitors
and like ice skating at the Olympic
level yeah is really cray yeah I do that
[ __ ] all the time
let's do it this Tarzan an ice skater
yeah Margo rub a pervasive language
violent okay
[Music]
there's no such thing as truth everyone
has their own truth
[Music]
Jeff was my first date ever and my mom
came to see a wholesome American family
an American family that's every year
fault was embarrassed you
you know what maybe I would whoa whoa so
nice to see Margot Robbie
we also judge on presentation
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
whoa it's insane to watch that that
looks badass
that looks insane man and I like seeing
Margot Robbie look like a person like
she's cute but like a ugly ugly equals
person being in this and it makes me
feel better about myself
ya know it's hard to live up to Margot
Robbie it is in every capacity and I
feel like I can attain this version of
Margot Robbie yeah this is it attainable
Margot Robbie for the average pretty
you're prettier than this version of
Margot Robbie compliments it's very hard
to make Arthur Robbie look ugly she
doesn't actually wait so this is crazy
to me like so she was this really
popular figure skater what did she do
that was like highly illegal cuz like
the FBI's getting robbed and stuff the
only thing I know about is the bashing
with the baseball bat yeah she had some
like crazy criminal activities
Goodfellas a figure skating there must
be like some high legal crimes stuff she
did right well Joe Pesci in this that's
what makes it home alone is the
Goodfellas a family yeah I think they're
saying Goodfellas because of this style
it's like hyper edited a lot of the
narration the talking to the camera I've
seen a lot of movies do that American
made did that recently I get kind of a
little bit I don't from the word is sick
of the style but it's getting kind of
repetitive when it's like dealing with
drugs and all these things what
fascinates me is it's about a figure
skater which seems all the more
intriguing yeah and I really like that
we're seeing women portrayed in more
ways than just like oh here's some girl
she's so nice and pretty and she's yeah
it's like the love interest this is
women being portrayed as a in depth
characters we're talking about
with ambition like that mom looks like
she's a single mom and she completely
probably passes the Bechdel test and all
of her scenes okay for those of you
viewers who don't know what the Bechdel
test is it was a test you could do it on
most any movie to see if in a scene two
women are talking about something that
is not a man it's really surprising but
up till recently it was actually very
difficult to find scenes like that in
movies it's super weird try it with
older movies up till just recent you
will see that you're like oh my god
that that's weird it's actually kind of
rare but I think most scenes with women
should be talking about men this is my
personal opinion if we want equality I'm
glad you're back today well actually go
off the mom I've known a couple of
figure skaters who are super traumatized
by the it's kind of economizing of like
the woman I met that have done ballet
when they were younger it's incredibly
competitive they're incredibly strict
it's so fascinating to me have these
like beautiful glorified performances
are really the ones where you get the
parents and the coaches who are just
ridiculously abusive to you especially
emotionally and it's double negative
especially in emotional I've never been
known to be good with my words anyway
you're really gonna see the story of why
she turned out to be the way she is and
I feel like there's gonna be that part
of me as a viewer that's like well I
kind of want you to do the wrong thing
and there's a sea there yeah I've always
been a competitive person and it's
something that I've had to like control
in my mind and like think through like
hey don't think that mean horrible evil
thought I thought maybe that's part of
being a grown-up is you like hear the
bad thoughts yeah I'm just gonna pitch
it's not a competitive people alone as
people in general but yeah for sure yeah
I want to explore that psychology let's
learn more about Todd yeah and to see
why I haven't beaten anyone up it's
awesome to see trailers with you where
you're actually into the trailer
yeah that's a great feeling to have on
my end
all right reject nation well thanks for
tuning in you can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell I never use this pencil but I have
one in my hand now Kat Alvarado all
links to her social media in the
description box including her YouTube
page although a list of her performances
in New York will be in the description
box for you people so if you're in the
East Coast make sure to catch her there
and if you're in LA she performs live
out here to I I caught one of her most
recent shows how long she had the crowd
of 10 people and stitches but it's not
because there's a small place that's the
way it is that's where your practice
which is good practice